Se nos pide dibujar la imagen del triángulo ABC
bajo una homotecia cuyo centro es P y el factor
de escala es 1/4. Pausa el video y piensa en cómo
harías esto. No tienes acceso a la herramienta que
estoy usando con la que puedo mover esto, en
realidad esto es un ejercicio de Khan Academy,
pero piensa en cómo dibujarías la imagen del
triángulo ABC bajo una homotecia cuyo centro es P
y el factor de escala es 1/4. Muy bien, trabajemos
juntos en esto. Una forma de pensar en esto es
que, ya que nuestro centro de homotecia es P y
nuestro factor de escala es 1/4 para cada uno de
estos puntos sin importar lo lejos que estuvieran
de P antes, ahora van a estar a un cuarto de esa
distancia, y podemos pensar en las dimensiones x
y y. De modo que veamos el punto A, por ejemplo:
para llegar del punto P al punto A tenemos que ir
1, 2, 3, 4 a la derecha y 1, 2, 3, 4 hacia abajo,
así que 1/4 de eso en la dirección de x y y en
lugar de ir 4 a la derecha y 4 hacia abajo sería
1 a la derecha y 1 hacia abajo porque 1 es un
cuarto de 4. Entonces, en lugar de 4 a la derecha
iríamos 1 a la derecha y en lugar de 4 hacia abajo
bajaríamos 1. Aquí es donde mapearíamos el punto
A. Y ahora pensemos en el punto B, para ir de P al
punto B en la dirección de y tenemos que ir hacia
arriba 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8. Bueno, ¿cuánto es
1/4 de 8? Es 2, así que ahora vamos a ir 2 hacia
arriba, y para ir de P a B ¿cuánto tenemos que ir
en la dirección de x? Bueno, tenemos que ir hacia
la izquierda 1, 2, 3, 4, en lugar de ir 4 a la
izquierda ahora vamos a ir 1/4 de esa distancia
o sólo 1 a la izquierda, así que en lugar de ir 8
hacia arriba y 4 hacia la izquierda ahora vamos a
ir 2 hacia arriba y 1 a la izquierda, 1/4 en cada
dirección. Por último, pero no menos importante,
para ir de P a C parece que vamos 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7, 8 a la izquierda y 1, 2, 3, 4 hacia arriba.
Si tomamos 1/4 de cada una de esas distancias, en
lugar de 8 a la izquierda ahora vamos a ir 2 a la
izquierda y en lugar de 4 hacia arriba ahora vamos
a subir 1. Y hemos terminado. Acabamos de crear
la imagen del triángulo ABC bajo una homotecia,
cuyo centro es P y el factor de escala es 1/4.